all right hello everyone how are you
guys all doing hope you guys are having
a wonderful day and today we're here
with another video so today's video will
be capitalizing on the recent Zoll run
nerf if you guys want to see more videos
like this of things that may have
changed and may be more profitable than
they usually have been go ahead and tell
me about that down below make sure hit
that like button but what we have for
you today is a method of getting sharks
that will allow you to profit for one if
you're a normal regular player of the
game seven to eight hundred K an hour
depending on when you're playing and on
top of that if you're an Ironman this is
going to be by far and away the best way
for you to go ahead and get sharks so
with that said obviously there are some
requirements while this is a low level
money making guide it does require a
little bit of cash if you're gonna want
to go ahead and do this method for an
hour's time you will need 420 K cash lit
and on top of that you're gonna need a
hundred percent piste gorillas favor so
if you guys do not know what that is
that pretty much is one of the current
houses so what you have to do is go
ahead and get a hundred and Pistor ileus
that's the only one I have any favor in
it's relatively simple I'm gonna go
ahead and show you guys what I did real
quick so alright so for those of you
that already have 100% Pisco Ilias favor
and don't need to look at the steps and
get it go ahead and skip on to 442 in
this video one thing that you can do you
can go ahead and complete the client of
'quran quest if you haven't done this
I'd recommend you do it as it is a ten
minute long quest it gives you 20% favor
in one house obviously I chose mr. Ilyas
and you get doubled favor for all the
houses so it's really helpful and that's
how you end up saving yourself a ton of
time with this as it will take another
hour to if you don't do the quest so if
you've already done the question you
can't put your 20% onto Pisco ileus
basically what you're gonna want to do
is come on over to this shop and if you
don't know where Pisgah elias is it is
over here you can voyage here from Port
Sarim and end up down here or I
personally use house tabs and then run
all this way which now I'm realizing
probably isn't all that efficient but
what you're gonna want to do make your
way on over to the general store you're
going to need nails a hammer and planks
more planks than I have here I'm just
using these as an example probably bring
about 500 planks and a thousand nails or
so and you should be good whatever you
have left obviously just sell on but
what you can do and
a little helpful hit for you guys so you
guys don't have to keep running to the
bank it back go ahead and note your
planks you'll sell them for pretty much
nothing as you guys can see here they
will buy literally for nothing
you can buy them back for one coin so 28
coins to save yourself running all this
way
it sounds pretty decent to me and all
you're gonna need to do is go on over
here and for a pair the fishing great
now you will fail and it will take a ton
of nails so that's why you know you
obviously have that many nails but this
is how you get your favor up from 1 to
15 now we will move on to the next part
which is taking all of this fish and
throwing it and kind of like a cooler I
guess so what you're gonna need to do is
come on over here to these three barrels
of fish just right south of where you
were before go ahead and pick them up
and they'll pretty much just spawn as
you can see right here and you just have
to keep on going down till you have a
full inventory now when you have a full
inventory you're gonna have to run east
into this little house where you'll kind
of need to know this house for later but
just deposit it in the cooling chest
pretty easy stuff you get a little bit
of fishing XP you'll get some slow favor
but it's the best you can do at that
level of favor so go ahead and do that
and then yeah once you reach 30 go ahead
and follow me and run north so once you
go ahead and run north basically when
you have 30% pissed gray Leah's favorite
you'll need to go ahead and go to the
bank take out a spade along with some
coins and run to the east now you can
bring a full inventory of buckets if you
have them available in your bank if you
do not though however it is not a big
deal go ahead and train this time Tainan
guy and he will have buckets for you so
we're gonna want to go ahead and do is
just buy a full inventory of buckets
obviously you'll have a full inventory
and not what I have here and go to the
north and dig up these sand worm
castings so as you guys can see there
are times where you will get 10 hunter
XP this does require 15 hunter and you
will get buckets of sand worms basically
you'll go ahead and turn these into the
guys south as you saw right there there
are times where you will fail and you
will not get any sand worms as you guys
can see so what you'll have to do is
just while you're digging another one go
ahead and empty out one of your buckets
of sand and over time as you guys can
see you will fill up your inventory now
this is extremely quick compared to the
other two and all you have to do is go
south and once you go down to Tainan
again all you'll have to do is just talk
to him he'll take the buckets off your
but as you guys can see you'll have no
buckets you trade them again fill back
up with buckets and you should be good
to go now this only takes like seven or
eight trips it's pretty quick and once
that's all done you'll have a hundred
percent piss Greeley's favor and I'll go
ahead and show you what I was doing to
get sharks so all that you'll need as I
said earlier some coins stamina potions
are recommended as you will be running a
decent amount so what you're gonna want
to go ahead and do is drink up on one
stamina dose and turn that into the bank
then as soon as you can
just start running south now I'll kind
of show you guys the way that I go about
getting there this method is really nice
for Ironman I mean I don't there's no
better way to get food I would imagine
on an Ironman especially after this is
over an earth it's always really like
passive way to go ahead and get sharks
it's really helpful this is kind of more
intensive but it definitely is worth it
if you're looking for some decent food
for whatever bosses you may be going
after and for the average player 700 K
or so an hour when you are a low-level
like there's barely any requirements
it's a really good method so we're gonna
want to do go ahead and go on into this
house with this purple side trade a
Franky and as you guys can see he will
have some he will have some sharks for
you now this is open to everyone so some
worlds may not have you know the maxed
out amount of sharks and may just have
one instead it really depends on what
time of the day you're coming here just
a little bit ago whenever I tested my
hours worth I was actually getting
pretty much open worlds everywhere but
as you guys can see we only have one
down here so what I recommend you guys
do is just hop to different segments of
worlds and kind of just have a relative
idea to where you are on the overall
world so as you guys can see I know I
didn't show it there but for all sharks
are insanely cheap from the shop so all
you're gonna want to do is go ahead and
buy your twenty five hop to another
world buy the rest of your inventory and
then you kind of know like as well once
hop into this world if you'll be able to
stay in this world for your next trip so
as you guys can see with 24 in stock
there are only 300 coins they do go up
to I believe 5 to 600 coins you're still
making money even if you were a regular
player and it's an Ironman obviously
that is worth it for you so what you're
gonna want to do just go back and you
will be at the bank I'll go ahead and
show you what an average ship looks like
as far as time and GP goes here in a
second alright so for an example I
started this trip with a
100 K and no rocks and no raw sharks in
my inventory so as you guys can see it
cost me nine pretty much 9k for this
entire inventory and when I go ahead and
price check these it says 25k they're
actually a little higher it sharks are
currently buying for 980 so there's
obviously a decent margin here and as a
man I would imagine this is something
that you would like to do
so overall whenever I was doing this
method I was able to get twelve hundred
and forty five sharks per hour now that
doesn't necessarily show here however
that's about 1.2 mil it's about 1.2 mil
per hour in sharks so that will be your
overall profit however the items you're
gonna have to put into this will be
stamina potions probably about eight as
they last for two minutes each well each
dose and then on top of that 420 K coins
is what you're gonna have to put in so
go ahead and take into account about a
460 to 470 K loss now there will be
times where you will have to stock up on
energy and I'd recommend doing that
using regular energy potions and you can
just drink them on your way to the shop
it's a relatively low cost and it
definitely helps out with the overall
speed of this as you will be losing run
energy so if we go ahead and revisit as
you guys saw you will end up spending
around 400 and let's say 80,000 per hour
however adding on the 1.2 mil that you
will end up making I got around 720 kgp
per hours so it's relatively good for
low levels I would say I mean 720 K and
the only thing that you need is just a
little bit of cash is absolutely insane
so it's definitely good for low levels
iron men definitely be using this method
I would imagine for sharks now since
fishing them is just not there's just no
way but that is it for me today so
hopefully you guys enjoyed the video if
you guys did make sure to leave a like
there's anything guys want to go ahead
and tell me any any video suggestions or
anything you guys have go ahead and
leave those down in the comments below
if you guys enjoy my content make sure
to subscribe to the channel yeah yeah
that's Eska be a wonderful day
[Music]